[موسيقى]
مشاريع وبرامج تنمويه في اليمن مبادرات
مستدامه تهدف الى تمويلها السعوديه عبر
برنامجها في سبعه قطاعات حيويه ضمن 229
مشروعا من بينها افتتاح مستشفى عدن العام
ومركز القلب الذي سيخدم نصف مليون سنويا
اضافه الى تدشين المرحلتين الاولى
والثانيه لمشروع اعاده تاهيل مطار عدن
الدولي من مدرج عدن رئيسي الى انظمه
الملاحه والاتصالات علما بان مشاريع اعمار
اليمن تجاوزت مليار دولار امريكي منذ عام
تستفيد منها اربعه عشره محافظه يمنيه
مشاريع من شانها ان تدفع عجله اقتصاد
اليمن وترفع كفاءه قطاعات البلاد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات